hello and welcome to hot tip the show
right to your controversial stands and
explain myself as if I was being
interrogated so lately I've been going
through the Dragon Ball films per your
recommendations some have been pretty
good and others have made me want to
question my choice of career today I've
decided I hate myself enough to watch
the four films recommended the least aka
the worst Dragon Ball films as chosen or
not chosen by you those are the third
Broly movie by Oberle curse of the blood
rubies the very first Dragon Ball film
sleeping princess and Devil's castle the
second Dragon Ball film and Dragonball
Evolution which if you'd believe it got
the same number of votes as blood rubies
and sleeping princess one vote they each
got one singular vote so let's start
with the most popular of the worst bio
Broly after having spent the last few
days at Norway on vacation nothing is a
greater slap back to reality than
watching by overly who okay bio burly is
easily one of the strangest films i have
ever seen and that's saying something
when you consider the subject is dragon
ball with weird slapstick and an even
weirder plot by a bro Lee is the only
Dragon Ball film that doesn't feature
Goku at all no way it follows Goten
trunks and Android 18 as they attempt to
pick up the money mr. Satan owes them
for throwing the tournament but
something interrupts this a very strange
man with an equally strange entrance
issues a challenge to mr. Satan with
motivations for doing so being equally
as childish and shallow as the original
Broly film they're sensing a trend
having been requested to fight bio
warriors mr. Satan 18 and the two young
sands make their way to the headquarters
that is essentially the entire plot to
the film and it brings us up to about 8
minutes worth of runtime how long was
the film again oh yeah 46 minutes the
mastermind behind all of this looks
utterly ridiculous and honestly so do
the bio warriors themselves looking more
like potty monsters from the original
Power Rangers series than actual
real-life threats but let's look at some
of the positives huh it is refreshing
gang to see more of Android 18 and mr.
Satan and then places the action is
quite fun most of the comedic moments do
fall flat on their face for me but there
are certain things here and there
involving mr. Satan that made me giggle
okay that's literally
I liked in this movie and pretty much
hated everything else rulli's designed
was probably his greatest quality in the
first film however in this film they
have done away with any expression and
for me once had in lieu of an animators
nightmare goo monster it looks small
surely ridiculous and is the main force
of antagonism for the remainder of the
film however this film's greatest sin is
the absolute worst sin any film can have
for me it is so damn boring the film
drags its bioengineered feet from story
beat to story beats belaboring every
single piece of exposition without
getting to the action until we're over
halfway through the feature and the
action in that latter half is so gross
to look at with bio Broly lumbering
around like a dung covered sasquatch
that it was honestly a struggle to get
through this entire film this is easily
at the bottom of my list as the worst of
these films I've seen so far and that's
pretty much everything I had to say
about bio Broly now onto the wooden folk
club starting with Dragon Ball The
Legend of Shenlong or curse of the blood
rubies if you're looking at the tub and
I'm just gonna say it white from the
beginning here this is much better than
the votes gave it credit for but path to
power did this much better as the very
first of the now numerous Dragon Ball
film library this movie is largely a
retreading of the pilaf saga with pilaf
swapped out for a brand new villain
design a brand new design that is
honestly kinda terrible the movie
employs a very classic style and
honestly doesn't age too well in my
opinion there are tons of static scenes
with little to no movement whatsoever
and with it's shorter runtime of just 50
minutes it spends way too long retracing
the steps of the show and manga in a
much less appealing way might I add all
the while Pat the power achieved
fantastic success in both of these areas
with that said like path to power
there's still tons to sink your teeth
into with the variations in the story
and the characters interactions the
classic feel is still very present in
this film if that's something you enjoy
and there's a nice action sequence with
the uncha - that keeps the film from
being too boring during the midpoint law
with that said the connecting threads
end quote new stuff this film brings to
the table comes in the form of this
little redheaded girl called pansy who
requires the help of Goku and the others
to protect her village from the main
villain of the film king gorillas
and he's not interesting at all and if
I'm being completely honest I don't
really care for this film story
whatsoever mostly because this is a film
that is largely based on the original
material and because path to power had a
much larger pool to draw from curse the
blood rubies in comparison with the
scene that they chose to introduce are
much less well known and honestly didn't
connect all that well at all
additionally a common complaint I've had
with these films has been how they felt
like extended episodes of the show and
thanks to Wikipedia I now know why
apparently these films were all designed
such that they represent what the show
currently has to offer visually and
thematically shown across Japan at fairs
and festivals to promote the anime and
manga early on these films took the form
of our creeks apps like the pilaf saga
and later became spin-offs like Cooter's
revenge and future reborn stories
inspired and visually similar to the
story being told at that time in the
manga funnily enough these films have
more in common with Dragon Ball Heroes
than they do with battle of gods
resurrection F and the latest Broly film
in 2018 and with all that said curse the
blood rubies I didn't really like this
all too much its story is a little flat
convenient and rushed while not offering
much of value at all fingers crossed our
next film does more speaking of which
sleeping princess is tied with
Dragonball Evolution with the same
number of votes that being one with
revolutions was a meme vote or not
doesn't much matter because the only
person voting for sleeping princess was
my editor say hi Nexus okay so this one
is about 40 minutes long deep breaths
next up is sleeping princess in Devil's
castle alrighty so the entire movie is
based around Master Roshi's training or
at least the early stages where both
Crillon and Goku attempt to find a girl
to convince Roshi to train them the only
difference being that he specifically
asks for someone in particular the
sleeping princess in Devil's castle and
that's basically if the story chronicles
have both Goku and krillen tackle his
castle and ultimately save the princess
while featuring all of the regular cast
you come to know and love some of the
humor in the race to get to the castle
is fun and the simple plot really helped
this during its short runtime there was
one moment in particular that
legitimately made me laugh out loud when
I saw it check it out
straight up I wasn't expecting that
reaction from Bulma and it's gotten a
bigger laugh out of me than pretty much
anything the other films has gotten I
should also mention at this time that
Bullman as well as the rest of the crew
in their attempt to reach Goku managed
to get themselves wrapped up in the
castle situation
strangely enough during this section
with Goku and krillen exploring the
creepy surroundings it reminded me a lot
of their episode in Dragon Ball super
where they explored the forest which as
it happens was another fetch quest
issued by Roshi amidst the chaos of the
castle launch shows up guns a-blazing
and it's honestly really cool to be
perfectly honest I love launches design
as the blond version and seeing her is
always a treat turns out she's just
there to collect the diamond which
happens to be the sleeping princess but
all goes downhill from here as launched
sneezes our heroes all get captured by
the villain Lucifer yes that's his name
and his evil plan is about to come to
fruition however he didn't Bank on one
thing Goku transforming into the oozaru
through the combined efforts of Goku and
the rest of the party they all escaped
unharmed bringing back launched to meet
Master Roshi the end honestly this is
exactly the sort of movie I wanted from
early Dragonball there's tons of new
material and it only utilizes plot
points for the manga to set the stage in
a very bare-bones sort of way the
villain is fun the adventure is
captivating and the action is so
distinctly old-school Dragonball I very
much enjoyed this movie and now finally
Dragonball Evolution from 2009 unlike
the vast majority of these Dragonball
films I've rewashed in this channel
evolution was one I actually saw in
theaters day one it was released around
the time I had stopped watching
Dragonball entirely but I was
nevertheless excited to see my favorite
characters on the big screen in order to
go see this I had to convince my family
including my mother and brothers who had
no interest in seeing this film to go
with me as I honestly had no one else to
go with so we made it a family day out
so to speak I still remember the feeling
of embarrassment and confusion I had
leaving the theater that day trying to
convince myself that it wasn't that bad
but let me tell you
it's that bad and a whole lot more
literally nothing in this film works
from the CGI to the choreography to the
casting to the god-awful script this
film was written as though my mother
wrote it we are talking about a script
so fundamentally broken that the writer
of that script issued a public apology
years later stating that he just needed
the money this is a film featuring
characters that are only like the
originals by name and nothing else this
is a film that had help offered by the
license holders including Akira Toriyama
himself and denied the option this is
the film that inspired accurate Orianna
to make battle of gods and start the
modern generation of Dragonball
so I guess something good came out of
this mess of a film film that even if I
was to take a look at it as its own
standalone thing not taking inspiration
from anything is still a tone-deaf
nonsensical amateurish teen martial arts
movie that has no idea what it actually
wants to be what I wants to say and
plays as if it's embarrassed of what it
is
this is by far the single worst most
disappointing film I have ever seen in
my life
and I refuse to watch it again and so
its conclusion time with all the films
I've seen over the last month or so this
is what my rankings of these films looks
like right now number one as the best
Dragonball film I've seen is path to
power
number two is fusion reborn number three
wrath of the Dragon number four sleeping
princess and Devil's castle was
surprisingly good number five the
world's strongest number six brouilly
the legendary Super Saiyan number seven
cooler's revenge number eight Bojack
unbound number nine curse of the blood
rubies number ten dead zone number
eleven is bio Broly and at a distance
number twelve by far the worst
Dragonball Evolution now looking at this
at first glance you might be led to
believe that a large chunk of these are
actually pretty good movies but if I'm
being completely honest apart from path
to power and fusion reborn the other
films I've seen have had moments where I
had fun sure but in general didn't offer
enough for me to care to watch them ever
again and when you drop below the fifth
spot on this list there's just awful
film after awful film in my opinion but
that'll do it for this week subscribe
for more if you want to see it and I'll
see you all next week
thank you so much for watching
you
[Music]